here's something you don't see every day
new england is bracing for what could be
its first direct hit from a hurricane in
30 years henri is the name it's a
tropical storm for now but it's expected
to strengthen and could make landfall
this weekend cbs news meteorologist and
climate specialist jeff beridelli is
watching it all for us jeff good morning
to you hey good morning tony and good
morning everyone so big changes
overnight last night and we have reason
to believe that this shift westward is
real we'll talk about that in just a
couple of seconds but in the meantime
you can see the storm right now it
hasn't strengthened overnight but it's
likely to strengthen during the day
today winds are right around 65 miles an
hour we expect later today it probably
will become a hurricane so this is why
we believe this westward trend in the
computer models it's because last night
hurricane hunter went out sampled the
environment we took all that really
important data fed it into the computer
models and they spit out a shift to the
west that means it looks like this is
coming in a little closer to places like
long island it puts a lot more of the
coastline into jeopardy here so the
bermuda high right now is tracking this
west but it's going to find a corridor
right in between the two systems as it
does so take a look at this ocean
temperatures two to five degrees above
normal so this is going to fuel a
stronger system and notice at some point
the area of low pressure catches on re
and it starts to capture it and push it
westward and also notice
that little zigzag that means the system
is going to slow down as it gets close
to shore could batter this whole area
from new england to long island for as
much as 24 hours or so this is the
official forecast track from the
national hurricane center as it moves
northward you can see where it's located
on sunday making landfall but notice one
of our computer models much further west
in fact a lot of them further west than
the actual track from the national
hurricane center that means we have to
watch anywhere from new york city but
especially east into long island and new
england you should have your hurricane
plan in place right now if you live in
that area anthony oh not good news jeff
thank you